we of the American film industry are
proud indeed to extend a hand across the
seas to the creators our brother fellow
creators who have given so much to the
art of the cinema world now presenting
to the present the award tonight for the
best foreign film of 1958 here are miss
Donna winter formerly of South Rhodesia
and mr. Fred Astaire formerly of North
Nebraska
good evening rods thank you good evening
good evening down on Fred you know I
didn't know where did you dance so well
I saw you walking like that it was
absolutely beautiful
oh I wasn't dancing Roz it's just that
when you're walking Freddie makes you
look that what oh well fed if your card
is instilled where we have the next walk
Donna shall we read the list of foreign
films
no I've I don't you start all right the
nominees are one the devil came at night
glory of film Germany two gates of Paris
films on our si production France three
Mother India
Mabel productions India for the nights
of Cabiria
Dino De Laurentiis production Italy five
nine lives nor to appear Norway who's
the winner fair Willer is nights of
Cabiria
Dino De Laurentiis production
miss the Giotto Messina accept the award
for mr. Dino De Laurentiis for the
director Federico Fellini for myself
thank you thank you very much